[Applaudissements]
les
à
madame
vivre une vie de star
mallet
à
bah
qui tombait dans son message
[Musique]
toi alors on va vous happe et surtout on
est au chômage
allez merci les gars merci c'était super
non arrêté en fait vous jouer très mal
[Rires]
merci à vous les voiles et par
l'atteinte ou changez vous aimez
[Applaudissements]
par là
lequel puisque est sur la traite des
noirs
je fais ce avec quoi parfois le matin en
réunion par sur des trucs et on se dit
c'est une bollier quand arrive le soir
si ce qu'on appelle une fbi ait dans le
métier une fausse bonne idée d'égaliser
plus arrivé j'ai dit maintenant quelle
race rats non mais ça y est j'ai dit je
savais que c'était une place du sexe
mais ils ont joué franchement ils ont
joué le jeu le problème c'est que ce ne
sont pas des comédiens